saluons né en janvier 2019 ça veut dire
que ça fait deux mois que je suis pas
allé me faire passer la couenne de la
fesse ou laser ça veut dire aussi que ça
fait deux ans que cette belle aventure a
commencé un deux ans déjà et ça veut
surtout dire que c'est le moment d'y
retourner
et comme d'habitude vous venez avec moi
à l'ego
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
je
m
[Musique]
c'est parti
voilà c'est fini bon je vais pas pouvoir
vous faire le petit débrief tout de
suite parce que j'ai des trucs à faire
je vous fais ça a vite fait genre de
rang un jour ou deux en même temps je
sais pas pourquoi je vous dis ça vous
vous en doutez les couilles pour vous
c'est dans une seconde procureur n'a
juste pas j'aurais changé de tee-shirt
quoi j'en ai profité pour aller chez le
coiffeur
ça ne vous a pas échappé puisque vous
êtes extrêmement perspicace donc petit à
petit débrief de la séance bah c'est en
somme toute assez classique les réglages
étaient les mêmes que ceux de la
dernière fois c'est à dire un petit peu
plus proche de la technologie du switch
qui était la première que j'avais
employé mais quand même avec une finesse
qui est permis peuvent été permise même
par là par les nouveaux appareils donc
voilà c'est les réglages de fin de
traitement
même si vous verrez à la fin qu'on est
quand même pas à la fin du traitement
donc voilà du coup bas la douleur la
même même protocole ponot de pomone
anesthésiante une heure avant des
sensations un peu picot tante may
mais pas de grosses douleurs donc voilà
faut que je vous ai dit ça je vous ai
pas dit grand chose ya pa de 9 mai avant
de passer à la comparaison visuelle du
tatouage
j'étais un concert la dernière fois et
j'ai rencontré un sympathique abonnés
qui en plus de me parler de cirer les
com de cette coutume m'a posé une
question intéressante
il m'a demandé comment ça se passait
pour les peaux bronzées ou pour les
peaux mates ou pour les peaux noires ou
de type asiatique et c'est là comment
est-ce que ça se passe eh ben je vais
vous répondre
en fait pendant longtemps le laser pour
le détatouage notamment c'était des
conseillers pour les peaux dix ans les
poppys menthe et précisément parce que
le but du laser c'est de fragmenter les
pigments de tatouage et que avant les
anciennes techniques ça à fragmenter
tous les pigments sens sans distinction
et du coup ça risquait de d'éclaircir la
peau au à l'endroit du à l'endroit du
des tatouages
du coup le pigment du tatouage partait
mais à la place y avait le tracé du
tatouage en plus clair sur une peau
foncée donc c'était peu intéressants
avec les progrès des machines de
détatouage il ya maintenant possibilité
de régler les paramètres de la machine
pour cibler vraiment les pigments
les pigments des encres de tatouage du
coup maintenant c'est possible pour les
peaux foncées ou en tout cas pigmentées
du coup le conseil que je donnerais si
c'est votre cas
renseignez-vous quand même parce qu'il
ya des dermatologues des lazaristes etc
qui sont spécialisés dans les po dans
les peaux foncées donc peut-être c'est
bien de se renseigner avant est de
savoir si le médecin vous allez allez
voir gère ce genre de ce genre de
technique c'est important je remercie
l'abonné qui m'a posé cette question
parce que c'est vrai que c'est très
intéressant
j'en avais pas je n'en avais pas parlé
si vous avez des questions n'hésitez pas
parce que c'est vrai que je j'ai répondu
à mon petit gars personnel mais
peut-être que vous avez des questions
qui vous concernent ou juste des trucs
que vous demandez comme ça mais
n'hésitez pas à me les poser par les
moyens habituels facebook twitter
instagram les commentaires via jumelles
une adresse mail d'edx qui est question
dtc @ gmail point com
donc n'hésitez pas à me poser vos
questions et dans la mesure du possible
je j'y réponds et alors
d'ailleurs puisque l'on parle d'eux des
messages et des échanges marchands etc
j'en profite pour revisiter un truc vous
êtes encore très nombreuses et très
nombreux à m'envoyer des vidéos de
détatouage c'est incroyable où on a
l'impression que tout parent tout de
suite comme ça d'un coup alors je vais
pas refaire l'explication de ce que j'en
ai déjà parlé ya pas très longtemps mais
sachez juste que non ça n'existe pas les
méthodes instantanée de détatouage au
laser ça n'existe pas ce que vous voyez
sur les vidéos ça n'est pas c'est pas
mes tatouages qui disparaît comme ça
d'un coup
donc ce que je vais faire plutôt que de
me répéter je vais vous mettre la ola
dans une petite bulle un lien vers la
vidéo où j'explique tout ça comme ça
j'allais dire une bonne fois pour toutes
sans doute pas mais au moins voilà ça
répondra à la question pour les gens qui
n'a pas encore la réponse
n'hésitez pas à les rejeter un petit
coup d'oeil vous verrez que non c'est
pas c'est pas il n'y a pas de méthode
magique et donc on en arrive au moment
de comparer les le tatouage
avant et après c'est en tout cas ce qui
s'est passé entre les deux les deux
dernières séances
donc je peux sans plus attendre je vais
pas vous faire je vais pas vous faire
mariner voilà la photo juste avant la
séance
il ya à peu près deux mois maintenant
donc ça avait bien bien progressé par
rapport à la séance encore avant donc
j'étais très content et voilà la photo a
juste avant la toute dernière séance la
salle il y à il ya quelques jours
maintenant puisque comme je vous ai dit
j'avais des trucs à faire c'est moi
c'est moins spectaculaire que entre les
deux séances précédentes
d'ailleurs je ne vous cache pas que le
médecin lui même était un petit peu
circonspect en refaisant son calcul vous
arrête ça quand même cette séance là on
avance mme on n'avance pas vite
alors ce à quoi je réponds oui ça fait
cette séance avec vous avec le pico
jours mais j'avais déjà fait cette
séance de 2 kg ou switched avant donc
oui je vous confirme que ça traîne un
petit peu ça fait deux ans maintenant
mais bon temps je sais que ça fait ça
fait ricaner certains parfois parce que
tu me trouve trop optimistes mais
vraiment je vous assure c'est vrai que
là c'est moins spectaculaire que entre
les deux séances d'avant mais ça
continue à disparaître
gentiment évidemment on voit les traits
qui reste on voit pas aller très con
disparu c'est c'est logique c'est bien
mais mais aussi on fait vraiment une
comparaison avec le tout début de
plus tu as toi je continue était tout
frais voilà vous voyez bien en toute
bonne foi qu'ils continuent à se passer
des choses
rd il ya plusieurs endroits où les
traits sont complètement partie il ya
d'autres endroits où il reste presque
plus rien on voit qui a dû du pigment
encore un petit peu au fond mais ma foi
voilà donc ça continue c'est très long
plus d'accord avec vous voilà la
démonstration que je voulais faire
c'était est-ce que c'est eux aussi
rapide que ce qu'on nous vend banon
voilà voyez moi ça fait deux ans alors
oui c'était un tatouage très récent mais
après tout c'est quand même parfois le
parfois le cas et au delà d'être un
tatouage récent parce qu'on s'est
interrogé avec le médecin pourquoi est
ce que ça prend autant de temps la
première réaction un petit peu spontané
ça a été bien avec quoi ils vous ont
tatoué quand même machin donc je lui ai
redit ce que je vous ai déjà dit l'encré
utilisée c'est vraiment lancre de base
noire en plus donc pas difficile à faire
partir donc ce n'est pas de ce côté là
qu'il faut chercher
on s'est mis d'accord le médecin et moi
sur le fait que c'est plutôt
probablement une histoire un peu de
profondeur de d'ancrage de d'injection
puisque c'est de ça qu'il s'agit
et sûrement aussi de quantité d'encre
donc ça veut dire que si vous voulez
allez vous faire tatouer le studio
galère laourou julliard et abat monte à
tous et cesse vous pouvez y aller ce
votre tatouage va pas passer au bout de
au bout de deux mois
mm il m la dose et il envoie le truc
bien profond oui je vous voir et canet
mais non c'est pas de ça que je parle
donc maintenant qu'est ce qui va se
passer là je vais encore attendre deux
mois puisque on est resté sur les mêmes
réglages qui étant un petit peu plus
agressif pour la pour la peau nécessite
qu'on la laisse un petit peu au repos
outre le fait qu'il faut aussi laisser
le temps à mon organisme qui peut-être
un petit peu paresseux ne sais pas
peut-être chercher de ce côté là aussi
le temps de d'éliminer
le lancre qui a été fragmentée donc pour
ce qui est du vidéo des tatouages je
vous donne rendez-vous dans deux mois
mais évidemment d'ici là on va se revoir
sur dtc y aura d'autres vidéos et qu'est
ce que je vous propose d'ici là mettez
vous bien et surtout
[Musique]